we are living in a time of flux with
jobs lost to automation while other jobs
require specific skills and
qualifications
and with 2022 rolling in if you are
giving your career some consideration to
make sure you are future proofing your
skill set or perhaps moving into a new
field altogether here's everything you
need to know about the top 10 highest
paid tech jobs in 2022
so let's look at them one by one at the
10th position we have systems analyst
in this role you will design techniques
to aid in problem solving by analyzing
it systems in the organization
they're responsible for fixing the
issues in a cost
manner as an analyst you will also test
programs and databases to make sure
they're running properly as well as run
security audits and documents on systems
in the organization
some skills and requirements for this
job role are analytical skills data
analysis and programming skills
technical analysis and project
management the average salary of systems
analysts in the us is about 145 000 usd
per annum and in india it's about 16
lakhs rupees per annum at the ninth
position we have blockchain engineer a
blockchain engineer specializes in
developing and implementing architecture
and solutions using blockchain
technology
the worldwide spending on blockchain
solutions is expected to reach 15.9
billion by 2023 meaning there will be
plenty of demand for blockchain experts
across industries and geographies
given the fact that cryptocurrencies are
surging blockchain technology has a long
way to go
from a bird's eye view a blockchain
engineer should have
solid programming skills and a thorough
understanding of the technologies behind
ripple r3 ethereum and bitcoin as well
as consensus methodologies and the
security protocol stacks crypto
libraries and functions the average
yearly salary of a blockchain engineer
in the us is about 150 000 usd and about
15 lakhs rupees per annum in india at
the eighth position we have product
manager a product manager helps
determine parameters around the product
while the engineering team leads the
development of that product from
conception to launch
some of the skills required for a
product manager are
a strong understanding of product
lifecycle management plm
knowledge of product management tools
like pivotal tracker jira and asana
strong analytical and time management
skills
product managers are responsible for
delivering an operating plan that can
help achieve strategic and tactical
goals and objectives building a product
portfolio managing and implementing
marketing activities and contributing to
the product strategy and its vision
the average yearly salary of a product
manager is over 160 thousand dollars usd
in the us and about 25 lakhs rupees per
annum in india at number seven we have
full stack developer
today there are over 23 million
developers globally and by 2023 it could
reach
27.7 million definitely making it one of
the highest paid tech jobs in the
industry
a full stack developer is someone who is
well versed in both front end and back
end development or someone with skills
in every stage of development from
concept to end product some of the
knowledge and skills required to become
a pro full stack developer is
technology such as mongodb
express.js angularjs and node.js how to
design and develop an api coding and
scripting the fundamentals of web
development basics of database
technologies
there is an ever increasing demand for
full stack developers in the market
today
the average yearly salary of a full
stack developer in the us is about 164
000 usd and in india it's about 11 lakh
rupees per annum however with increasing
seniority comes increasing pay next in
the list of the highest paying jobs is a
devops engineer a devops engineer is
critical to the project's overall
success right from planning to support
to customer satisfaction and
productivity a devops engineer has an
essential role in integrating the
project functions and resources across
the product life cycle right from
planning building testing and deployment
to support
some of the skills required of a devops
engineer include coding and scripting
understanding deployment and network
operations familiarity with devops tools
like git and jenkins knowledge of linux
or unix system administration
devops engineers might be responsible
for designing and maintaining a
deployment infrastructure integrating
cloud services so that processes can be
automated or shell scripting in php
python and ruby the average yearly
salary of a devops engineer in the us is
about 176 000 usd and in india it's
about 11 lakh rupees per annum at the
fifth position we have data scientists
there has been a 29 increase in demand
for data scientists year over year and a
dramatic upswing of
344 increase since 2013. and for all the
right reasons
a data scientist analyzes and interprets
complex data to help organizations make
better and more timely decisions a data
scientist should be able to understand
machine learning algorithms create data
models code and language like python r
sas and other analytical tools identify
business issues and provide appropriate
solutions excellent communication the
yearly salary of a data scientist can be
as high as 184
500 usd in the u.s and about 15 lakhs
rupees in india
next in the list of highest paying jobs
is cloud architect a cloud architect
deploys and oversees an organization's
cloud computing strategy
some of the skills and knowledge
required by cloud architects include a
thorough understanding of cloud
application architecture
knowledge of amazon web services azure
or google cloud platform good knowledge
of at least one operating system
computer programming languages security
and good communication skills
a cloud architect typically is
responsible for developing cloud
architecture developing a cloud strategy
and coordinating the implementation and
deployment of it and ensuring
application architecture and deployments
in the cloud environment are done
properly
the average yearly salary of a cloud
architect is 197 000 usd and 26 lakhs
rupees pa in india at number three we
have iot solutions architect one of the
most in demand and best paying jobs in
technology today is an iot solutions
architect the iot solutions architect is
a leadership role of overseeing the
strategy behind the development and
deployment of iot solutions in addition
to understanding iot solutions one
should also have strong programming
skills an understanding of machine
learning and knowledge of hardware
design and architecture
and in this highest paying tech job you
can earn an average of over 200 130 usd
and about 10 lakhs rupees annually at
the second position we have ai architect
an artificial intelligence ai architect
develops manages and oversees ai
initiatives within an organization an ai
architect should have deep knowledge in
mathematics and statistics in addition
an ai architect will have solid
programming skills and know python r and
torch
understand how tensorflow and other
similar technologies work have a clear
understanding about technologies related
to ai including machine learning neural
networks and deep learning the average
yearly salary of an ai architect is
about 230 000 usd and in india the
salary is about 63 lakhs rupees per
annum moving forward at the first
position we have software architect
a software architect optimizes the
development process by making design
choices and dictating technical
standards such as coding tools and
platforms the candidate will be
responsible for designing developing and
implementing software solutions to
address complex business issues and
providing technical leadership within
the it department some of the skills
required of a software architect include
data modeling an understanding of
software architecture good programming
skills and strong analytical skills the
average yearly salary of a software
architect is over 264
9447 usd and about 45 lakhs in india so
with that we come to the end of this
list although these are 10 of the best
paying jobs in technology plenty of
other fields like cyber security and
digital marketing are short on skilled
professionals so keep looking if none of
the careers described above appeal to
you
before i sign off make sure you
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update we'll
be back with more such interesting
videos until then keep learning and stay
tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here